let me pull up the story we got from the
daily mail police threaten to arrest
truckers blockading the us border in
alberta unless they leave cops give
freedom convoy an ultimatum after their
one-time cheerleader justin trudeau
turned on them for protesting his
vaccine mandates so
ultimately the the rcmp backed down
but is this them saying well you know
them the the mounties are leaving
because we've issued your warning we'll
come back later or are they completely
unable to do anything about these trucks
i mean that's kind of the thing right
and and hats off to rebel news um i
think the website is
convoyreports.com they have up i think
they have their demon a fundraiser for
lawyers by the way so what we're talking
about for people who um that aren't
familiar you have truckers right now
that are on the border
between alberta and montana that are
actually blocking the main roadway on
this and i pulled it up on the map this
is your basically your main border
crossing between calgary and the entire
pacific northwest so if you're coming
out of that main city of uh central and
this is a central agricultural hub this
is a cattle hub so your beef
some poultry that's all coming out of
there out of calgary out of that area
they're locking it all down and the
truckers are just basically standing
there saying look this is a standoff we
are not cut we are not going to move the
mounties and rebel rebel news as far as
i can tell are the only ones that
actually have people who are embedded
there because there's no way to get
there right now otherwise so it's like
the middle of nowhere but they're
putting up and i'm looking just a couple
of minutes ago
um the alberta premiere kenny just
declared that the blockade is unlawful
warning the participants are subject to
arrest and they're broadcasting so this
is like kind of like it's not like this
but it's similar to the bundy ranch
standoff that took place or the mulher
um reservation it's not like that in the
sense they haven't taken over you know
like a federal facility or anything like
that but this time around rebel media is
actually in there embedded so they've
just six minutes ago posted a video
of of the truckers releasing a statement
in response to the alberta premiere
saying look we want dialogue we want
communication and we want the mandates
this is a lot like occupy wall street
it's so much like occupation yeah you've
got uh you were mentioning earlier that
viva fry was on the ground for like six
hours six hours he didn't do 21. like i
did but he's cool guys
we're fantastic
but no no but he was you were saying
that you know he's going around live
streaming on the ground and you know
embedded in this moment
very similar to what happened with
occupy wall street not just with me
covering this and people were giving him
batteries people were like coming up to
him recognizing him and saying oh viva
yeah i need a battery pac-man and they
would give him a pack and then he went
into an office at one point and was
charging his phone but like interviewing
someone while he charged his phone i
mean it's crazy he was like meeting you
know uh
and there was like a singer songwriter
this girl who was there and she like
played amazing grace just for him and
he's talking to truckers and retired
people it was i honestly i kid you not i
was watching his live streams and then
just any live stream i could of these
trucker protests for like the last three
days straight so if you've been in my
house or if you've been at the studio a
town in dc literally you see me at the
computer all you hear in the background
is just hong kong
and i love it with every hunk it just
gets better and better i need to like
louder and louder yes more honking
absolutely so you see that's the big
difference if you are citizen journalist
you are in china on the ground reporting
live stream from the kobe side
you disappear very fast
you know
oh yeah
all those citizen journalists they are
locked up we don't know where they are
they could be dying of some disease or
something you don't know
if there's a big difference that's why
it's so important for people who love
freedom to appreciate what they have now
you've got to fight so hard to keep it
you know
if i can ask you lily what is one thing
that you think americans need to band
together and do right now to prevent our
country from becoming like the one you
left
well that that's why i'm running for u.s
congress right because i said why i'm
running because i failed the country i
love is becoming like the country i
loved
and it's getting worse and worse not two
years i could not sleep i saw the
writings on the wall
and i saw the similar tactics and
features what's going on in this country
with the mouse cultural revolution i
survived i just feel like it's like when
you see your neighbor's house on fire
they don't know
what should i do i see it i gotta warn
them right hey your house isn't on fire
so our country is going down that path
very fast i have to do something about
it and the last americans when i go out
to speak about my stories they're all
very interested in listening to me but
it's like how come they did not listen
to some stories learned hershey about it
before so
look into our educational system yeah so
are you are you running uh for the
libertarian party or i'm running as a
republican oh a republican yes i'm uh i
have around as before in colorado um
lp has no valid access and the
republican party in new hampshire is
quite good there are lots of people like
me inside to make things happening like
like lots of them in state house in
state senate we're passing some very
good laws right now i already passed
whole bunch last year that the
non-democrats trying to reverse them
they they're trying to sue our state now
to
forbid schools to teach discrimination
when race is more superior or interfered
than others what's wrong with that it's
in our state constitution you cannot
teach discrimination in schools but they
say well we cannot teach history anymore
we are so afraid of discussions of
slavery which is not true yeah i i i see
the memes all day and night so my my
facebook is comprised of
populists across the board i mean occupy
wall street is a big populist movement
and it's split in a lot of ways a lot of
people who supported occupy ended up
supporting trump later on many of one
for bernie so it's surprising when i see
the divide
and it really is a stark contrast
what i see from the left outright says
the right has stepped up to banning
books on slavery they're overtly racist
and white supremacist and like that's
just fundamentally not true it's a lie
they're pushing that lie about the book
mouse total lie total lie so they're
saying the book has been banned if
you're if your book is available on the
rack at barnes noble it's not banned
well if you can bring it into the school
and you can read it it's not banned
right so
the story is essentially that they voted
to remove from the curriculum it's like
okay there's a lot of books that aren't
in school curriculum they're not all
banned imagine if they were like you
know we have 500 books in the curriculum
that means 10 billion books are banned
that's insane but with the narrative
that's coming out is oh no they're
banning books they're banning books and
there's nothing you can say to change
any of their minds because there is a
tribal narrative another thing i want to
say that i testified in state capital
because the teachers union supporters
want to reverse our laws right and they
are suing our state and you got about 20
people showed up to testify support that
re um like the bill and you got the two
an agent you know women who fled
communism to give our strong two cents
there were totally outnumbered two to
twenty but we went there without the
paper front of us we just told our
stories and i called the nea i said well
if you look at nea national the largest
union national website they said clearly
budget to teach
critical register into 14 000 school
districts but the people say oh we're
not teaching critical research schools
really i said welcome you new hampshire
chapter of nea to come on make public
statement about that because i said if
on teach real history i'm living history
i would like to go to your school teach
your kids about communities how about
that yeah let's do it yeah yeah so they
should so you're uh
you're running for uh for the republican
uh uh nomination
yes there are five there are five
republican man in the primary with me
and i welcome all good men but i have a
compelling unique story
and i understand how precious our
freedom is
i feel confident with the grassroots
support hey everybody is watching please
lillytown williams.com ten dollars
and i can win i can be frontrunner
tonight you can make me frown under
tonight in the republican primary
to say hey we love lily she's
representing the common people and she
is a fierce freedom fighter why not let
her are you are you uh
are you involved with the free state
project
um i moved there and signed a pledge to
make maximum um efforts to create a free
society i was attacked for that by the
left when i was running for little
tongue supervisor of the checklist
because it's non-partisan race but when
they find out i was a free stater they
come attack me
and like it's like why i'm sh shouldn't
they be for freedom
i know or die so that's the whole point
progressives
come out organize workshops in the
libraries every election year to tell
people who are they free staters we are
the radical and right wing nuts
something like that they're saying so
they even don't understand how
organizations work everybody goes there
and once they sign a pledge you move
there you do whatever you want it's up
to you there's no dues there's no
requirement you're on your own and i
choose my own course you know so uh so
you're running for for federal congress
right yes and if i want a nomination i
will be the historically first chinese
immigrant from mainland china who
survived communism to be nominee of a
republican party in the country and then
uh when you get to washington will you
uh
do everything in your efforts to repeal
unconstitutional gun bans
you know and things like that of course
if you have nothing like
if you have not seen my unjung stuff so
interview
i was holding my ar-15
i love it in front of us flat i was
attacked also by some local left people
to say she look very scary they're a
loser she's holding ar-15 i said well
i am a survivor of communism i believe a
second amendment right otherwise all
those students in tiananmen square will
not be killed without a fight right
that's right and you tell me that i look
scary i'm a five foot one a chinese
woman and i'm very intimidating you know
so they're afraid of guns basically so i
think that's part of the problem people
are afraid of guns have they tried to
handle guns in children range when i
first came to united states first time
touch gun i was scared too
so i don't know what to do i was like oh
oh people say oh no no don't put my
people lady number one rule
you know husband this family is like oh
god i forgot you're from china you never
touch guns i feel so empowered when i
first time hold the gun in my hands fire
first shot yeah it's like wow because i
never had that feeling i was deprived of
gun ownership 1.4 billion chinese today
deprived
the self-defense right
that's why they are quiet that's why
they comply no matter how bad their
lives become you know what can you do
you know people don't realize about the
second amendment the left often says
what are you gonna do rise up against
the government blah blah no that's not
what it's about it's for one it's it's a
it's a force it's a force balancer so
you mentioned tiananmen square
they roll out these tanks right so so
and then basically
you tell me exactly what happened with
tiananmen square they came and they
killed all these students so what
happens that uh um one
the
um premier of china huyabang he was the
one not just advocate for economical
freedom he was talking about we should
have political freedom as well so we
were in college and like let's talk
about let's have a conversation what
kind of country we want can we become
western democracy countries people can
vote can have a dialogue with our
leaders so they were peaceful and but
when this leader died and they were
actually just going to tiananmen square
to moan his death lots lots of you know
those chinese you know and flowers and
all that but then
after a couple weeks and people start to
say hey we want to have dialogue with
our leaders they were not calling to
overthrow the government no they just
say can we have a dialogue can we be
represented can we have a continued
dialogue about political freedom like
right to vote and right to appeal rule
of law
and at the beginning and the government
were quiet and then more and more
students show up and more and more
students starting other cities of the
province like capitals like my hometown
and um even when guava chop visited
china that time by the time it was like
400 000 students yemen square and they
had to reroute for him to visit the
state so after that i heard that the
xiaoping when back then was the leader
and talked to the military in beijing to
say
and go rowing to the champions square
but the beijing troops knew
those were our best and brightest
students and peaceful they were not
going to kill them and you see citizens
come up bake them to leave and literally
offer them water and bread to when
they're hungry to say leave you know
they're not threats they're not counted
revolutionaries go home so beijing
general actually later got fired because
beijing troops left wow that then
xiaoping went back to hubei where wuhan
is capital to say
go to tiananmen square whole bunch of
young people county revolutionaries are
trying to overthrow the government
traders traders basically they kill them
all
ten thousand estimated to be to die then
so what people need to understand about
the second amendment
that that story what would what what
would have happened if they actually
were armed i don't think it would have
escalated to a major conflict it would
have escalated to a dialogue because the
government would be like look we're not
going to go in there people there have
have weapons and we don't it could go it
could go south real quick so we need to
figure out how to defuse this in the
united states a lot of these you know
large instances these these large
moments where people the left is like
what do you think you're going to do
rise up against the government blah blah
blah no it just never escalates that
point because no one they know that
there's a mutually assured destruction
but a really good example of the
deterring effect and the the balancing
uh the force balancer is the brianna
taylor story the police kicked the door
in briana taylor's boyfriend returned
fire hitting a cop with a bullet the cop
was bleeding from the leg they fired
they killed brana taylor
but they were note the charges were
dropped against the boyfriend because he
had a right to keep and bear arms and
defend his home that means the police in
this country know
a law-abiding citizen may be armed and
if you try and break into their house
and violate their rights you could die
you could die and and the per and
grandchild's boyfriend did not get in
trouble i mean they they pushed him
through it a little bit but eventually
he just was like look it was it was it
was a lawful self-defense of his house
so in a country like you look at these
videos out of australia or the uk the
cops kick the door and they walk and
they do whatever they want in the united
states
not so much still yes they do but not so
much well that's why um if you look at
my past 2013 i published open ad by
national review online to say like a
guns against tyranny
and i talk about yemen square i talk
about chinese people feel powerless to
defend themselves their families and
anybody can kick your door open and
we i was told when i leave a very poor
in literally working parents
neighborhood say hey if criminals come
go grab
our choppers in the kitchen like when
you
like do bones and chickens you know your
souls
chopsticks don't do any sense so you
have to just grab the knives you know so
when i come to this country when i first
time got
passionately involved in politics
because 2013 the democrats in colorado
wanted to limit the ar-15 magazines so i
testified first time i did not know how
to testify in this long line i had to go
in with somebody
my smart
rat is like a like my husband called me
straight red i survived china so i said
i'm not going to get it in there testify
they're lying so long it'll be midnight
but i saw somebody's expert witness like
a president of rocky mountain governor
association say
hey
can i go in with you because i survived
china i want to give my two cents he
said okay come with me so i went in with
him first time i testify in my life in
my new country to say what you're doing
is a communist way i we need to have a
second mind to the right to defend
ourselves is our god-given right are you
becoming like a communist well nobody
said anything but they passed the bill
along the party tonight i become
political activist after that what's
good for you
yes let's turn my mouse chairman mao is
the one who said this perfectly
political power grows from the barrel of
a gun
and then what did the ccp do they banned
all the guns well when the prc funded
1949 my dad told me he remembered
because before that some people still
have some guns even though nationalist
party by shanghai she also started to
have gun control north because you know
he was kind of corrupt too but after prc
they commonly said turn over all your
guns whatever you have in your house
including those people who are supposed
to be kind of like a little bit like a
malaysia group turn your guns oh we
search door by door
then you go
to jail you will find a gun in your
house i i love this point um i hate that
i'm able to make it when these you know
democrat type say no one is trying to
take your guns away i just say waco
and then they'll if they don't know what
it is i'll be like how many children are
worth killing so that you can take guns
there will be rage yeah you know there
are lots of cases to prove and the
people
unless some people will say i guarantee
you one hundred percent that our
government in the u.s will not become
tyrants
who can guarantee that if you don't
trust that then
gunk debate is over it's it's simple
over a long enough period of time a
system that has centralized authority
you
if you have a hundred leaders
and you have a system of centralized
authority and 99 of them are good people
but you end up finally getting that one
dictator then he goes nuts and and
seizes more power and kills people it's
we just shouldn't have that centralized
kind of power just like a mall right
most like social past so you don't have
a rule of law you have a rule of man
what if you run into seven mad men and
when i was growing up as one madman
sociopath 20 million people died during
his cultural revolution so so you go
through the cultural revolution in china
you come to the us you're in colorado
and you said 2013 i think right
and now
how do you i mean i kind of asked you
this already but seeing everything
that's going on right now it's got to be
kind of like
nerve-wracking you're like i i left
trying to get away from this and now
these countries are doing similar things
and they're ramping up towards this this
you know authoritarianism well that uh
um like defectors from russia they said
that too see the you know they will
corrupt the free world one little bit
socialism
and every day so they sell you free
stuff first so our young people need to
realize that free stuff it's what they
use to get you
an interesting and socialism because
every equity i mean they don't realize
that is a company's term so once you get
into the door you vote for them and they
have total control oh all of a sudden
you cannot vote anymore yeah you cannot
have guns anymore you cannot have a
private property anymore and your
children don't belong to you they belong
to this state and you don't have a
medical decision anymore you know we
have seen plenty of that in the past two
years that's why
i feel like i can do more now by going
to wrong
for office so i can't get my messages up
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you